Oh, bin ich am Start.
Steiner Adler.
Fünf, wohlgemerkt.
Dankeschön für den Zap.
Das ist sehr exzellent.
Es kann übrigens sein,
ich sage euch aber auch,
dass das nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich ist.
Allerdings, es kann sein,
dass ich weg muss im Stream.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Weil ich habe heute Nacht
beziehungsweise heute Abend
und heute Nacht bis morgen früh
Rufbereitschaft.
Also kann sein,
wenn irgendwas ganz
gravierendes kaputt geht,
dass mich dann irgendeiner anruft
oder zumindest,
dass unser Monitoring-System
irgendeine Nachricht schickt,
die ich dann gucken muss.
Aber es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Im Großen und Ganzen
läuft das erstaunlich fehlerfrei
für das, wie viel Wildwuchs wir haben.
Also machen wir mal eine Runde Präge,
dass das nicht vorkommt,
nicht nur, wo man pennen kann.
Auf der anderen Seite,
so schlecht ist das auch gar nicht,
wenn was ist nachts,
weil man muss ja elf Stunden Abstand halten
zwischen letztem Einsatz und Arbeitsbeginn.
Und den Rest der Zeit kriegt man aufgefüllt.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
wenn ich nachts Einsatz habe,
kriege ich quasi fast einen Arbeitstag gratis.
Fast.
Gibt es den Friseur noch?
Ja, der Friseur hat gestern oder vorgestern,
irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
sechs Stunden oder so Gears of War gestreamt.
Gears 5, glaube ich, sind sie gerade.
Ja, ich würde ja auch gerne,
also allgemein muss ich überhaupt mal erst mal wieder ein Video machen.
Aber ich würde ja seit Jahren schon mal gerne wieder mit dem Friseur was aufnehmen.
Und ich weiß, der Fabian, der will, eigentlich will er das auch.
Aber der kann sich immer nicht durchringen dazu, das zu machen.
Ja.
Aber mal gucken.
Vielleicht gibt es, vielleicht gibt es ja demnächst eins.
2012 YouTube.
Also, ich gebe dir recht, ich hätte 2012 YouTube gerne zurück.
Allerdings ohne, dass ich Call of Duty Content machen muss,
dann auch wieder zwangsläufig.
Weil da hätte ich jetzt mit dem Ganzen nach all den Jahren ja auch keinen Bock mehr.
Aber YouTube könnte durchaus ein bisschen wieder sein wie 2012.
Ich kann dieses ganze super gehypete Influencer,
diese Influencer-Sachen, damals gab es das Wort Influencer noch nicht mal.
Ich kann das, kann mir das alles, alles, ich bin, ich bin da zu alt für mittlerweile.
Das war früher nicht ganz so schlimm.
Heute ist es ja,
keine Ahnung, heute muss, muss sich ja jeder wegen jedem Shit erst mal drei Stunden entschuldigen.
Und es posten sogar irgendwelche Werbepartner,
öffentliche Statements, das ist alles so gestört mittlerweile.
Ja.
Folgt das nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich, mich interessiert das auch nicht.
Ich kenne die meisten Leute noch nicht mal, die an irgendwelchen Beefs beteiligt sind.
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, ich kenne die nicht.
Ich habe von denen schon mal was gehört, von den meisten, ja.
Weil ich bin ja immerhin irgendwo noch ein bisschen auf YouTube und ich gucke auch auf Twitter rum.
Und das eine oder andere kriegt man mit.
Aber ich kenne in Form von, ich habe schon mal den Stream gesehen oder Videos geguckt oder gar nicht.
Null.
Ich kenne die alle nicht.
Ich kenne die vom Namen her, aber ich weiß null, was die für ein Konrad machen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon, ich habe es schon ein paar mal erzählt.
Der einzige Beef, den ich ein bisschen mitverfolgt habe, weil ich super lustig fand, war KuchenTV versus Shoriyoka.
Ey.
Das war YouTube Beef and its best.
Das war schon wieder lustig.
So bescheuert war das.
Aber den ganzen anderen Klempel, der ist mir vollkommen egal.
Da geht mir auch so richtig am Arsch vorbei.
Ich will das gar nicht sehen.
Ja, das ist wirklich so.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wobei, wenn ich YouTube in einem privaten Tab aufmache, da kommt ganz viel Fußball immer.
Scheinen in Deutschland eben viele zu interessieren.
Ach ja, nice.
Nice.
Aber nicht im offiziellen, oder?
Aber nicht im offiziellen App Store.
Im offiziell inoffiziellen.
Ach doch, ja, okay.
Ich frage mich, wie das ist.
Gibt es gescheiten.
Controller Input für, für iPhones, weil du kannst diese ganzen Games ja ohne einen gescheiten
Gescheiten Controller gar nicht richtig spielen.
Genauso wie Leute, die einen N64 Emulator da drauf laufen haben.
Ist ja schön und gut, dass es läuft, aber ich möchte trotzdem nicht N64 Spiele mit Touchscreen
spielen müssen und auch nicht mit Emulated Analog Stick auf dem Display und so.
Das ist ja beim Mobile Game schon, schon Schrott.
Ja, geht das?
Habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Aber wenn das geht, ist gut.
Dann, dann passt's.
Ja.
Ja, ja, dann ist gut.
Wenn das geht.
Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Das wäre der Friseur.
Klar streamt er auf Twitch.
Der heißt jetzt nur aus irgendwelchen Gründen anders.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Das hier ist er.
Ja, E-Mail Adresse liegt, die ich immer nicht nur für Fake Account Registrierung verwendet
habe.
Der hat aber irgendwie die letzten Broadcasts nicht aktiv.
Der war, wie gesagt, gestern oder vorgestern.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Aber er ist auf jeden Fall noch am Start, wie er früher immer so gesagt hat.
Der hat sich mehrere Stunden mit Gears of War zurückgemeldet.
Wir Haben mal kurz Package-Updates.
Soll ich euch mal was ganz tolles von Vodafone
erzählen?
Wusstet ihr das?
Ich warte mal, bis meine VM an ist.
Dann kann ich schon sayaan.
Wusstet ihr, dass Vodafone Super WLAN hat?
Wurde ich letztens darauf hingewiesen.
Vodafone Super WLAN.
Und was meint ihr, ohne nachzugucken?
Ohne nachzugucken, okay?
Was meint ihr, was Super WLAN ist?
Es ist...
Ich kann euch jetzt schon spoilern.
Es ist nichts Besonderes.
Wi-Fi 7, 5...
Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Leute, ihr denkt viel zu kompliziert.
Ihr denkt viel zu...
Super WLAN?
Ist nichts anderes wie die Funktion,
die so gut wie jeder andere
nicht super low budget Access Point beherrscht.
Nämlich, sich einen möglichst unbenutzten WLAN Channel raussuchen.
Das ist alles.
Das ist Super WLAN.
Und das kannst du dir irgendwie zusätzlich buchen und sowas.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung.
Okay, kostenlos, ja.
Mesh System.
Ist klar, Mesh System.
Mesh System, ja.
Einen, ja.
Aber der Name ist schon mal toll, oder?
Ja.
Übrigens, zum Thema Marketing.
Ich hatte heute auf der Arbeit irgendjemand von...
Von, frag mich nicht, von der Marketingabteilung in einem Teams-Call.
Und die haben die ganze Zeit irgendwas erzählt mit...
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen.
Irgendwas mit Liefervereinbarung oder Ergebnisse oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja.
Und da hab ich die gefragt, ist das nicht so, dass das...
Also, ich muss dazu sagen, ich weiß das aus meiner YouTube-Geschichte und die ein oder
anderen Sponsor- und Werbesachen, die ich dort gemacht hab, ja.
Also, ich kenn so ein paar richtig sinnlose Marketingbegriffe.
Ich will damit zwar nichts zu tun haben, aber die einen oder anderen kenne ich, ja.
Und da hab ich die gefragt, sagt man da heute nicht, wenn man im Trend sein will, Deliverables dazu?
Ich kann das nicht richtig aussprechen, aber die wussten bestimmt, was ich meine.
Aber wir sind so oldschool, dass wir nicht die coolen, trendy Marketingwörter verwenden,
sondern wir suchen irgendwelche deutschen Übersetzungen.
Also, Leute, merkt euch das.
Wenn ihr mal bei Marketingleuten irgendwie so tun wollt, als habt ihr Ahnung, das nennt sich Deliverables.
Also, wenn's drum geht, beispielsweise, ihr macht irgendein Sponsoring und der Typ oder irgendeine Werbeplatzierung,
was der Typ euch liefert...
Was der Typ euch liefern muss, ja, oder was ihr liefern müsst, die coolen Leute nennen das Deliverables.
Und nicht irgendwie Lieferergebnisse oder Ziele oder whatever.
Deliverables nennen das die coolen Leute.
Aber wir wollten nicht.
Da sind wir zu oldschool für.
Ach ja, wirklich?
Ja, was mach ich jetzt mit meinem Lizenz-Key?
Ich will aber nicht upgraden.
Das ist aber sehr nice.
Ich will aber nicht upgraden, weil das letzte VMware-Zeug ziemlich kaputt ist.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das sehr gut.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das wirklich sehr gut, dass das jetzt kostenlos ist.
Es gibt ziemlich eigentlich gar keinen Grund mehr für VirtualBox.
Leider hat VMware in den letzten Jahren an Workstation auch schon relativ wenig gemacht.
Und ich fürchte, jetzt damit wird da wahrscheinlich noch weniger dran gemacht.
Dabei ist Desktop, eine gute Desktop-Virtualisierung, legit eines der wichtigsten Anwendungsfälle für mich, die es abzudecken gilt.
Und da gibt's ja eigentlich nur VirtualBox und VMware Workstation.
Was gibt's denn da sonst noch?
Mir fällt nix ein.
Ja, wir müssen uns eh überall registrieren.
Wir müssen auch für jedes Game einen eigenen Launcher installieren und einen eigenen Poops-Account bei... frag mich nicht...
...mypoops.com oder whatever machen, damit wir uns das Game installieren können.
Was sagst du zu Google?
Ich hab nichts damit... gar nichts davon verfolgt.
Auf jeder Post, da gibt's schon genug Keys.
Da muss meiner nicht auch noch hin.
Jetzt mache ich meine Package-Updates. Ich wollte doch Package-Updates machen.
Habe ich das jetzt gemacht oder nicht?
Oder habe ich es verpeilt?
Ja, ich habe es verpeilt. Keine Package-Updates.
Ah, das brauchen wir heute nicht.
Ja, es ist kurz vor der Vollendung, dass ich mein Geld bekomme.
Ich habe gestern vom Anwalt den Brief bekommen.
Die haben jetzt alles bezahlt und jetzt kommt der Ha... also diese Versicherungen, ja...
...die sind so unglaublich unfähig.
Die haben jetzt sogar zu viel Geld überwiesen.
Und das ist ja in den zweiten Tag später aufgekommen.
Und jetzt wird ein Tag später aufgefallen.
Und jetzt wollen sie 80 Euro noch zurück haben.
Allein schon, der Schriftverkehr mit meinem Anwalt kostet jetzt mehr als 80 Euro.
Also Fachkräftemangel scheint da wirklich ein Ding zu sein, ne?
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist in letzten Zügen.
Also ich müsste das Geld entweder heute, morgen oder übermorgen irgendwann demnächst auf dem Konto haben.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz im Ernst, auf die paar Tage kommt es jetzt auch nicht an.
Es ist eh lächerlich, dass es überhaupt erlaubt ist, so lange zu brauchen, das alles zu überweisen.
Auf der anderen Seite, irgendwie ist mir das auch egal.
Ich habe eh mir mittlerweile ein neues Fahrrad gekauft.
Und das jetzt früher oder später kommt... was?
Kein E-Bike, das Fahrrad hier, guck mal.
Habe ich das nicht mal gespeichert?
Wir hatten doch mal ein Kommando, oder?
Ausrufzeichen Fahrrad.
Moment, das ist das falsche Kommando.
Weil das gibt es nicht mehr.
Hatten wir das nicht?
Hatten wir das nicht geupdatet auf dem Internetarchiv-Link?
Wir hatten doch... Moment, Moment.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das gerade mal kurz machen.
Ich suche das mal raus.
Archiv.
Org.
Ja, das war der richtige, aber ich bilde mir ein, wir haben es letztens schon geupdatet auf das Internetarchiv.
Wenn nicht, können wir das jetzt schnell machen.
Ich pause das mal kurz rein.
Ja, das ist mein Fahrrad, kein E-Bike.
Guck mal, ob man die Ausstattung ausklappen kann hier unten.
Ja, kann man. Sehr gut. Ja, dann kann man das verlinken.
Einzige Sache, die ich modifiziert habe, ist das hier.
Ich habe hinten nicht 11-34 drauf.
Ich habe hinten 11-40 drauf.
Ja.
Habe ich umgebaut.
Ah ja, und, und...
Was ich auch noch gemacht habe, ist...
Ich habe alles entfettet.
Und die Kette gewachst.
Hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anstößig an, aber ich meine es wortwörtlich.
Und das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Eine gewachste Kette.
So, wir haben Package-Updates gemacht.
Reboot.
Mein Anwalt sicherlich mehr.
Ich kann es dir noch nicht genau sagen.
Ich kann es euch erzählen, wenn ihr...
Wenn ich das Geld auf dem Konto habe.
Meinen Gewinn habe ich ja gar keinen gemacht, in dem Sinn.
Wenn schon, habe ich Ausfallentschädigung, oder wie das heißt, bekommen.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen.
Ich hatte letztes Jahr im, weiß ich, Oktober oder so den Unfall.
Und die haben es jetzt...
Schaffen sie es vielleicht Mai.
Oktober, November, Dezember...
Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai.
Das hat...
Über ein halbes Jahr gebraucht.
Ja, irgendwie so.
Kette wachsen ist gerade in Mode.
Ich glaube, es ist mittlerweile easy genug, dass es viele Leute zu Hause machen.
Ja, da bist du... du hast verloren, ne?
Finanzamt ist eh das geilste, was Überweisungen angeht, ja?
Die brauchen teilweise ewig, bis da irgendwas... bis die irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegen.
Aber wenn du einen Zettel kriegst...
Steht immer schon hinten gleich drauf, was dir droht.
Rechtsbelehrung.
Und dann hier. Ja, ich hab doch hier gerade wieder was liegen von denen.
Ähm...
Andernfalls zahlen sie bitte die rück... die rückständigen Steuern, beziehungsweise Abgaben.
Innerhalb einer Woche.
Bam!
Die können aber ewig brauchen für...
Ähm, das eine hat ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Also, wenn ich denen was überweisen muss, dann muss ich denen was überweisen.
Ich meine, ich könnte denen natürlich eine Einzugsermächtigung geben.
Mal kurz was gucken.
Muss gucken, ob die Überweisung ans Finanzamt auch wirklich raus ist.
Weil ich hab keinen Bock, da irgendwie Mahngebühren oder sonst was zu bezahlen.
Äh...
Was ist denn?
Today? Yesterday?
Ja, Finanzamt. Okay.
Die Zahlung ist raus.
Als Instant-Überweisung.
Oh!
Lohn und Gehalt ist eingetroffen heute, sehe ich gerade. Nice.
Da freut man sich doch immer.
Exzellent.
Ach so, ja.
Ähm...
Ja, da hast du gelitten.
Da hast du Pech.
Da wurde schon alles...
Wenn du vom Urlaub wiederkommst, wurde schon alles gefendet, was bei dir im Hof auffindbar ist oder so.
Hey Max, bin nun acht Monate in meiner Ausbildung Systemintegrator.
Habe aber keinen Plan, was ich nach der Ausbildung machen will.
Mach dir keinen Kopf, das geht noch eine ganze Weile.
Acht Monate ist ja gerade erst mal richtig...
...noch nicht mal richtig akklimatisiert.
Mach dir mal keine Gedanken. Mach erst mal in Ruhe.
Zwei Jahre deine Ausbildung, ja?
Ja, macht doch nichts.
Mach mal zwei Jahre deine Ausbildung in Ruhe.
Und mach dir nicht von Anfang an so viele Gedanken.
Was hältst du von der Schweiz? Vielleicht irgendwann mal sein Glück dort probieren?
Wenn ich ein gutes Angebot kriege von einer Firma aus der Schweiz, was sich im Endeffekt lohnt.
Und der Berücksichtigung aller Sachen, die man da so berücksichtigen muss, die ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht weiß, aber mich dann schlau machen muss.
Ja, klar. Warum nicht?
Ich würde mich jetzt... Ich würde jetzt nicht aktiv danach gucken, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber mal angenommen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen kommt dann eine Schweizer Firma und sagt, Max...
...wir brauchen genau dich für die und die Sache.
Und ich finde, die und die Sache ist auch ganz toll.
Und wir bezahlen auch mega viel Kohle.
Bei uns ist alles furchtbar geil und Homeoffice und whatever.
Dann hätte ich keine Probleme, auch zu einer Schweizer Firma zu gehen.
Hast du Tipps, wie man das passte Thema Unternehmen für die Abschlussarbeit findet?
Bachelor in Form... Keine Ahnung.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass für deine Bachelor-Abschlussarbeit...
...etwas höhere Maßstäbe angelegt werden, als für ein fiesi Abschlussprojekt.
Dementsprechend... Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nachdem ich keine Informatik studiert habe und das nicht selbst... Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir sagen, wie du dein fiesi Abschlussprojekt aufbaust, dass die IHK das mag, ja.
Aber was du da machen musst, fehlt mir selbst die Erfahrung.
Hey Max, angefangen Informatik zu studieren. Ich tippe 40 Wörter pro Minute, sollte ich da schneller sein.
Ist vollkommen egal, wie schnell du tippst.
Du wirst mit der Zeit und der Übung schneller.
Du wirst irgendwann auch feststellen, du musst gar keine Wörter mehr ausschreiben, wenn du dich ordentlich auf der Kommandozeile auskennst.
Und außerdem, es kommt viel mehr darauf an, was du tippst, als dass du es jetzt übermäßig schnell tippst.
Das ist genau das... Das ist so ein Argument, was ich nie verstehe, ja.
Die ganzen Wim-Enjoyer... Also ich meine, ich benutze Wim auch täglich.
Einfach, weil es der beste Editor ist auf der Kommandozeile und es auf jedem System drauf ist und weil man viel per SSH unterwegs ist.
Aber die ganzen Wim-Enjoyer, wenn ich die da immer argumentieren höre...
Ja, Wim, da hast du immer deine Finger auf der Home-Row und die schnellste Time von Brain to Keyboard und sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, Leute, ich weiß ja nicht, wie ihr programmiert, aber bei mir ist Programmieren, sagen wir mal, mindestens 50% überlegen und 50% tippen.
Realistisch betrachtet sind es wahrscheinlich eher 80% überlegen.
Und 20% tippen.
Ja, und ob du die 20% jetzt immer so in, keine Ahnung, 3 Sekunden Burst schreibst oder ob du da ein bisschen langsamer bist, macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Ich kann jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht einordnen, wie schnell 40 Wörter pro Minute sind.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich hinkriege. Ich habe das irgendwann mal ausprobiert, aber...
Das Ding ist...
Selbst wenn ich es jetzt teste, ist mein Ergebnis wahrscheinlich sehr schlecht, weil ich zig Schreibfehler mache.
Was nicht weiter wild ist auf der Kommandozeile, weil die meisten Sachen kannst du...
Also, complete ich eh aus der History und Änderung.
Da passiert nicht so viel und im Zweifelsfall geht das Kommando nicht.
Oder wenn es Teams ist, dann habe ich zur Not Auto korrekt oder schick es einfach so ab.
Also, ich korrigiere nicht jeden Schreibfehler.
Ja, bei mir auch.
Ja, ist genauso.
Meinung zum Einsatz von KI beim Programmieren, insbesondere GPT-4, mir fehlt...
Was fehlt dir enorm?
GPT-4?
Achso, dir gefällt das? Ja.
Also, ich glaube, du nutzt das genau fürs Richtige.
Das ist das, wofür ich es auch benutzen würde.
So als Denkanstoß.
Und zum Überprüfen, also wo ich das ganz gerne verwende, ist, wenn du irgendwie...
Beispielsweise, du hast irgendwie ein riesiges Ansible gedönst, ja?
Wo du keine Ahnung genau hast, was das macht.
Und irgendwie ist halt die Dateiberechtigung auf deiner Datei falsch am Ende vom Ausführen, ja?
Und du findest es einfach nicht.
Da kannst du das bei ChatGPT reinpacen und sagst, hier, warum hat die Datei...
Keine Ahnung, 755 soll aber 700 haben oder so.
Für sowas ist ChatGPT ganz gut.
Auch um Syntaxfehler zu finden.
Wohlgemerkt, Syntaxfehler...
In YAML-Files ist ChatGPT ganz gut.
Weil, ihr kennt das vielleicht, YAML-Files haben ja streng genommen eigentlich kaum Syntaxfehler.
Aber sie sind trotzdem falsch, logisch.
Weil, sie sind nicht syntaktisch falsch, weil es könnte ja ein neuer Block mit Einrückung sein.
Aber sie sind logisch falsch, weil der Block an der falschen Stelle ist.
Das funktioniert dann einfach nicht.
Also für YAML zum Suchen, was da nicht richtig eingerichtet...
Warum das vielleicht verkehrt sein...
Da ist ChatGPT auch ganz gut.
Ja klar, es ist viel besser als ein YAML-Parser.
Ein YAML-Parser kann dir sagen, dein YAML ist syntaktisch korrekt.
Dass du aber einen Block falsch eingerückt hast, das checkt ein YAML-Parser nicht.
So, und...
Ansonsten muss ich sagen, ist ChatGPT bei mir von Anfang an ein bisschen unten durch gewesen, seit ich das das erste Mal ausprobiert habe.
Weil es hat so krass reingeschissen, ChatGPT.
Bei meiner Übungsaufgabe, die ich mal gepostet habe.
Das war doch ChatGPT 3.5, wohlgemerkt.
Als das ganz neu war, habe ich gesagt, ey guck mal, das halbe Internet ist am ausflippen, du musst das jetzt auch mal ausprobieren.
Und ich habe ChatGPT damals eine ganz, das haben wir sogar glaube ich im Stream gemacht, eine ganz simple Aufgabe gestellt.
Und zwar, ich wollte in .NET, also ich wollte die Sharp Source Code haben, von ChatGPT.
Was einen Download Progress Balken anzeigt, ja.
Datei runterladen, also Command Line, Command Line, Progress Balken, beim Download von der Datei.
Das ist, wenn man weiß, wie man es macht, ist das nicht...
Ist das easy.
Ja, ich müsste kurz überlegen und gucken und in 20 Minuten ist das fertig.
So, und ChatGPT hat angefangen mit, das hat dann so Dinger geschrieben wie...
httpclient.onProgress
Das Ding ist nur, httpclient hat kein OnProgress Event.
Das gibt es einfach nicht.
Das hat sich ChatGPT einfach ausgedacht, dass es das gibt.
So, und dann habe ich ChatGPT gesagt, ey ChatGPT, die Methode gibt es nicht.
Und dann hat ChatGPT gesagt, ach sorry, hier ein neues, hier ein neu generiertes Beispiel.
Und da kam eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung raus.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Einfach random eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung.
Da habe ich gesagt, okay ChatGPT, ich lasse es bleiben, zisch ab.
Und seitdem habe ich das für solche Sachen gar nicht erst wieder angefasst.
Einfach für so Syntax-Überprüfungen, wobei das ja keine richtige Syntax-Überprüfung ist.
Dafür ist das echt...
Also gerade für YAML-Dateien ist ChatGPT gut.
Und insbesondere für Kubernetes-Files.
Wofür, also wenn ihr Kubernetes-YAML-Files bekommt, die beispielsweise irgendeinen Helm-Chart generiert,
und das macht nicht genau das Richtige, das generiert ja immer relativ viel Output,
da könnt ihr das dann reinpasten und sagen, ey sag mir mal, ja keine Ahnung,
warum ist das Startup-Command falsch?
Und dann sagt er, ah ja, hier klar, Startup-Command, oder Command,
oder Arcs, ne Command heißt es glaube ich, ist falsch eingerückt.
Ja, das haben schon viele gesagt, ich muss das nochmal, die gleiche Aufgaben mit ChatGPT 4 probieren,
aber das fand ich so unterirdisch schlecht, dass ich mir das jetzt noch keinen Bock hatte.
Was findest du besser, VisualBox oder Hyper...
Du meinst VirtualBox, oder?
Möchte ein bisschen in PowerShell verbessern, weiß aber nicht welche...
Hä?
Weißt du was?
Das Chat-Comment hier, ich weiß, dass du es nicht bist, das klingt AI-generated gerade ein bisschen,
weil das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum brauchst du, warum brauchst du eine VM, um PowerShell auszuprobieren?
Ich meine, du kannst das natürlich machen, ja?
Also, fangen wir mal erstens, fangen wir mal erstens an.
Was findest du besser, VirtualBox oder Hyper, wie keines von beiden, VMware Workstation?
Guck hier, VMware Workstation, beste, VMware Workstation, ja?
Also, Hyper-V schon mal gar nicht für Desktop-Virtualisierung und VirtualBox,
ja, kann man ausprobieren, wenn man Probleme mit VMware Workstation hat,
aber nehm' VMware Workstation.
Ist sogar ab heute kostenlos, habe ich gehört.
So, wie du dich am besten mit PowerShell verbesserst, ja, er ist wahrscheinlich PowerShell benutzt.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich vielen Leuten mit Linux immer rate.
So, hier, wie kann ich das machen und hier jenes und wie kann ich da Know-How aufbauen?
Das Beste ist tatsächlich, Linux tagtäglich benutzen zu können.
Einfach benutzen erst mal, ja?
Gar nicht hier irgendwie krasse Scripting-Hackermans-Gedöns machen wollen,
sondern einfach mal benutzen.
Durch das tägliche Benutzen und sich mit den ein oder anderen Problemen auseinandersetzen, die man da so hat, ja?
So, was weiß ich, wo liegen meine Config-Files, wie klone ich auf der Kommandozeile irgendeinen Git-Repo,
ja, wie bediene ich meinen Terminal, wie bediene ich meine Shell, wie richte ich irgendwelche Sachen ein?
Da musst du dich zwangsläufig mal früher oder später mit allen essentiellen Parts deines Betriebssystems auseinandersetzen, ja?
Ja, wie, ups, Entschuldigung, okay, Festplatte ist irgendwie voll, irgendwie ist die Verzeichnisstruktur aufgebaut,
wo finde ich irgendwie meine Devices, wenn ich da was machen will, wie formatiere ich einen USB-Stick und sowas?
Da kommst du, wenn du das einfach tagtäglich benutzt, früher oder später mal so gut wie an allen Stationen vorbei.
Und hast am Ende enorm viel gelernt.
Also am besten ist echt tägliches, tägliches benutzen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich vermute, dass das mit PowerShell ähnlich ist.
Ich hätte keinen Bock, tagtäglich PowerShell unter Windows zu benutzen.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das auch die beste Variante, ja?
Wobei, man muss ja sagen, mittlerweile, guck mal hier, mittlerweile gibt es PowerShell auch für Linux.
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt unschlüssig, wann und weshalb und warum.
Und wieso ich das benutzen sollte.
Aber es geht auf jeden Fall, wenn man Hardcore-Windows-PowerShell-Fan ist.
Es gibt doch Edge für Linux, ja?
Mal gucken, ob es das auch für Arch-Linux gibt.
Warum hat denn das, Alter?
Das müssen ja echt Leute verwenden.
Guckt mal, das hat 116 Upvotes, das Package.
Warum hat denn das so viel?
Und, und, und, but why?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Aber, ja, was willst, was willst du machen?
Wo soll ich anfangen, wenn ich Ansible lernen möchte?
Unter Linux auf jeden Fall solltest du anfangen.
Ich glaube, man kann Ansible auch ganz gut unter Windows verwenden.
Da fehlt mir aber die Erfahrung.
Da müssen wir mal den Chat fragen.
Chat, wie gut ist der Ansible Support unter Windows?
Ich habe früher zwar nie was mit Ansible unter Windows gemacht.
Aber ich habe mal kurzzeitig Puppet unter Windows verwendet.
Falls das noch jemand kennt.
Und das war enormst Painschamp.
Wirklich ultra Painschamp.
Ich finde den Chat immer geil, wenn der Chat so random Dinge einstreut.
NixOS größer Ansible.
Wenn es gerade darum geht, ob Ansible Windows abfackeln kann oder nicht.
Sie passt richtig gut dabei.
Okay, geht so, ja.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe es mit Chat-GPT4 noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer VirtualBox-Fan.
Schon hast du TerraCrunt gemacht?
Nee.
Raw Terraform, beste.
Schon das Repo gesehen, das du gepostet hast?
Nee.
Ich sehe auch kein gepostetes Repo.
Muss nochmal posten.
Was ist das für eine Shell, hat irgendjemand gefragt.
Wo ist das?
Hier, ist das Zethash?
Ja, das ist Zethash.
Das ist hier Echo Shell, das ist Zethash.
Allerdings, ich verwende kein Plugin Framework mit Plugin Manager und 50.000 Sachen in meiner Shell.
Meine Shell ist tatsächlich relativ raw.
Ich habe natürlich einige Sachen drin, die das Leben einfacher machen.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich nichts aktiviert.
Also hier ist mal meine, ich habe Magic Zeug aktiviert.
Ich sollte, wisst ihr, ich müsste echt mal, das könnten wir eigentlich mal in einem gesonderten Stream machen, ja.
Ich könnte mal meine Shell ordentlich konfigurieren und das hier kommentieren, dass ich weiß, was was ist.
Ich hatte diese, meine Zethash-Config ist Try and Error entstanden.
Ich hatte irgendein Problem, was mich genervt hat und habe gegoogelt, was für eine Option ich setzen muss und dann habe ich sie gesetzt.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf, was das da macht.
Push D Ignore Dubs.
Keine Ahnung, Push D Silent.
Auto Push D.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, ich müsste das mal kommentieren, dass ich wüsste was.
Ich glaube Auto Push D ist folgendes.
Wenn ich in ein Verzeichnis drinne war und wechsel jetzt das Verzeichnis.
Dann kann ich mit 1, 2, 3 die letzten Verzeichnisse, in denen ich drinne war, durchschalten.
Ich glaube das, ich glaube das ist das.
So und dann, ja. Keine Ahnung, was das alles macht.
Vor allem ZStyle, Completion, Matcherlist, M, Regex, Zeug. Keine Ahnung.
Und natürlich, und natürlich das hier. Ganz klar, ganz klar.
If Test Minus T Null und und Dollar Minus gleich Y.
What?
Okay, ernst gemeinte Frage. Chat, was macht das?
Vielleicht kriege ich raus, wofür das ist, wenn ich das hier suche.
Enable X on, X off.
Ah, ich weiß was das ist.
Das ist Control S.
Abschalten.
Glaube ich. Ich glaube das ist Control S. Abschalten.
Control S freest normalerweise deine Shell.
Control S freest normalerweise deine Shell. Für irgendwelche prehistorischen Reasons.
Und das schalte das ab.
Was das hier macht, habe ich allerdings keine Ahnung. Ich glaube T...
Was war?
Ach ne, da muss ich glaube ich hier sogar gucken.
Ja, fuck man. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe kein Schimmer, was das macht.
Ich... oder...
Ich weiß nicht. Was ist das? Info oder so?
Ach ey, keine Ahnung mehr, wie man sich diesen Build-in-Shit überhaupt anzeigen lässt.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier macht.
Das testet Whatever auf Null.
Chat, wer mir das erklären kann, kriegt einen Giftsub.
Wir machen jetzt...
Erklärt dem Max seine eigene Shell-Config, please.
Also ich weiß, was das hier macht. Es schaltet...
Es schaltet...
Control S ab, relativ sicher.
Chat-GPT. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, Chat. Das machen wir jetzt.
Wir fragen Chat-GPT. Und zwar DuckDuckGo.
AI-Chat.
Was macht das hier in meiner...
ZSH... äh... äh... RC.
Machen wir mal die Zeilennummern weg, sind wir mal so nett.
Dieser Code...
...überprüft, ob das aktuelle Terminal ein interaktives Terminal ist.
Wenn dies der Fall ist, ja okay, aber... aber wie macht es das?
Einzelheiten erklären.
Okay, jetzt HighIQ.
Das ist eine Bedingung, die überprüft, ob das aktuelle Terminal...
...ein interaktives Terminal ist.
Aha!
Ah ja.
Minus T überprüft, ob der Dateideskriptor starre Input mit einem Terminal verbunden ist.
Okay.
Das heißt, wenn ich ZSH in irgendeinem Skript ausführe, oder irgendwie SubShell-mäßig, oder was auch immer...
...dann wird das nicht ausgeführt.
Das ist eigentlich sehr sinnig, aber...
Aber das...
So, und Minus Dings I überprüft, ob das Shell-Flag...
...I in der Umgebungsvariable enthalten ist, was zeigt, dass die Shell im interaktiven Modus läuft.
Alles klar!
Das checkt, ob es eine interaktive Shell ist.
Nice!
Für sowas ist das praktisch.
Ja, so.
Dann habe ich noch Dinger...
...keine Ahnung, äh...
Ich glaube, das brauche ich, dass ich mit 1, 2, 3, 1 bis 9 Verzeichnisse durchspringen kann.
Dann setze ich meine History auf...
Ich weiß, mittlerweile geht das auch besser.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es History, sei es Unlimited auch schon.
Ich glaube, man muss das mittlerweile gar nicht mehr setzen auf so einen hohen Wert.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es irgendeine Option für Unlimited.
So.
Das hier sind irgendwelche Keybindings für Spezialtasten, wie zum Beispiel POS1 und Ende, die manchmal rumbuggen.
Nicht in Bash, aber in ZSH.
Ja, das ist hier der Home-Datei-Ende-Knopf.
Das Ganze mit Doppel-Escape ist drinnen, damit es, glaube ich, auch potenziell über...
...in einem T-Mux funktioniert.
Dann...
...dann das Alt plus Raute funktioniert.
Okay.
Das Alt plus Raute funktioniert zum Auskommentieren von Zeilen.
Das ist sehr nice, sehr praktisch.
Ich erwische mich immer wieder dabei.
Dass ich so mache, ja.
Aber eigentlich ist Alt plus Raute viel nicer.
Also, das ist zum Beispiel praktisch, wenn ihr irgendwas tippt, so hier so.
Also, ich will jetzt hier irgendwas kreppen, plupp, keckel, Dings.
Und jetzt denkt ihr euch so, äh, Moment mal.
Was, was musste ich jetzt nochmal kurz nach?
Was, was musste ich machen?
Ah, das habe ich im vorletzten Command doch getippt.
Dann macht ihr einfach so.
Guckt hoch, was ihr tippen wollt.
Und dann macht ihr weiter.
Wie gesagt, das geht alles auf 500 verschiedene Varianten.
Ja, man kann auch das Ding in einem Editor aufmachen, die komplette Zeile.
Das mache ich, das mache ich so gut wie nie.
Man kann auch quasi das hier in einem WIM starten lassen und dann, äh, besonders lange Zeilen editieren und so.
So, History Search, vorwärts und rückwärts.
Wort vor und zurück.
Ja, das brauche ich auch oft.
Also, Wort vor und zurück ist hier, dass ich das machen kann.
Guckt.
Hä, jetzt geht es auf einmal eben was broken.
Keine Ahnung.
Guckt, dass es wortweise vor und zurück springt.
Ach ja, und wer sich jetzt fragt, wie zum Teufel soll ich denn überhaupt diese Escape Sequenzen hier rauskriegen?
Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach.
Ihr macht einfach Cat auf und tippt mal was ein.
Ja, macht mal hier zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich habe jetzt Alt gedrückt und Pfeiltaste links.
Und da seht ihr, ach, guckt mal.
Backward Word.
Da wisst ihr, was ihr hier eintragen müsst.
Dann habe ich irgendwas zum Ausrechnen von Prozessspeicher und Zeug.
Das brauche ich aber gar nicht mehr.
So, Aliasse für alle möglichen Config-Files.
Wetter, ganz wichtig.
Wetter in Hanau.
Wetter ist sehr nice.
Kann man jetzt...
Mit Image Support, Leute, hat das mittlerweile.
Mit Image Support.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das...
Ist das gerade down?
Ist Wetter in gerade down?
Oder schon?
Schon länger?
Oder...
Oh, das ist ja doof.
Ja, das ist down.
Scheint broken zu sein.
Warst du letztes Jahr auf der Bundeskarte?
Schau in Fuller.
Nee.
Du wusstest, du hast meine Schirme am Hauptmann aufgehört.
Die Chancen sind, auch wenn man da ist, doch sehr gering.
Aber möglich ist es, ja.
Möglich ist es.
So, Wetter.
Image Flash.
Image Flaschen.
History, dass das immer die komplette History ausgibt.
Dass LS standardmäßig farbig ist.
Zwei Sachen, weil ich es mir nicht merken kann.
Ohne Scheiß.
Das Beste, was ich...
Oder eines...
Alter.
What the fuck.
Nutzt du es aktiv?
Ja, aber nicht hier auf meinem Streaming-Rechner.
Privat nutze ich das aktiv.
Legit eines der besten Sachen, die ich je in meine Bash-RC eingefügt habe.
Irgendjemand von unseren High-IQ-Leuten, ohne Chat-GPT im Chat, der weiß, was das macht.
Das ist super High...
Also, nicht super High-IQ, aber mega praktisch.
Und zwar...
Ihr könnt es ruhig reinschreiben.
Das dauert ein bisschen zu erklären.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel...
Peckel.
Ah, das gibt es schon.
0w123.
Okay.
Ja.
So.
Wenn ich jetzt hier ein paar Sachen anlege.
Machen wir irgendwie mal 1000 Dateien jetzt hier angelegt.
So.
Es kommt ja total oft vor, dass Leute sowas hier machen.
Ja.
Sagen wir mal.
rm-rf 0w123.
Dann fragt er dich.
Ja.
Wollen Sie das?
Recursive?
Entfernen?
Dann musst du sagen, ja.
Und das kommt daher, weil das minus i da dran steht.
So.
Und jetzt kommt es.
Ich lege das Ding nochmal an.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal von Hand mache.
Ja.
Bin rm-rf.
Und jetzt machen wir mal.
Ich habe es irgendwie irgendwann schon mal gezeigt.
Ja.
Jetzt machen wir mal minus i.
0w123.
Ich habe es falsch rum gemacht, glaube ich.
Oder ist das?
Oder ist das nicht immer so?
Ja.
Genau.
Jetzt wirst du nämlich nicht gefragt, obwohl das minus i da steht.
Guck mal.
Das heißt, was zuerst steht, zählt zuerst.
Also selbst wenn ich interactive angebe und danach minus force rm, dann überschreibt
das minus i.
Okay.
Das ist ganz weird.
Und hiermit stelle ich sicher, dass egal was ich eintippe bei rm-rf, das minus interactive
immer am Ende steht.
Und es gibt auch noch einen Unterschied zwischen den, ja.
Es gibt auch noch einen Unterschied zwischen klein i und großem i.
Großem i ist.
Ne, ich glaube, das ist Absicht.
Das ist Absicht.
Das steht hier auch irgendwo, dass das das überschreibt.
Ja.
So.
Das ist Absicht.
Ja.
Gib mal.
Und den Unterschied zwischen kleinem i und großem i ist, bei kleinem i fragt er dich
von jeder Datei, ob du die entfernen willst.
Immer.
Und bei groß-i fragt er dich nur, wenn es mehr als drei Dateien sind.
Also nur wenn du wirklich die Chance hast, viel kaputt zu machen.
So.
Und, ja, also wenn ich jetzt.
Gehen wir irgendwie rein.
So, hier sind hier jetzt nochmal touch.
Quatsch, wir sind jetzt tausender Treinen drinnen und wenn ich jetzt sage, hier M-RF Sternchen, dann fragt er mich, ja, und dann, bäm.
Weil es sind ja mehr als drei.
Und wenn man nicht mehr genervt werden möchte, weil das Ding auch zig Unterverzeichnisse hat und sonst was, dann muss man einfach Yes nachher M-RF pipen.
Dann geht das auch.
So mache ich das, dass ich nicht aus Versehen was lösche und dass ich nicht solche behelfsmäßige Dinger brauche wie ein Papierkorb.
Es gibt ja ein paar Kommandozeilen-Tools unter Linux, die aliasen dann RM auf, dass es nicht mehr RM ist und verschieben die Dateien aber eigentlich nur in so einen Papierkorb.
Und seitdem ich das habe, habe ich nie wieder irgendwas aus Versehen gelöscht, nie wieder das Falsche gelöscht.
Und auch schon gar nicht.
Und gar nicht irgendwie zu viel gelöscht, weil wenn es zu viel ist, dann musst du das noch in Yes davor pipen und das passiert nicht aus Versehen.
Kann man so Functions auch in Bash?
Ja, ja, ja, das geht eins zu eins in Bash auch so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die allereleganteste Variante ist, das so zu machen, aber das funktioniert bei mir ganz gut.
So, und der Rest ist glaube ich nicht mehr so interessant irgendwie.
Wobei ImageCat ist auch noch nice, weil meine Shell kann ja Bilder, was ja das allerwichtigste Feature überhaupt ist.
Ganz wichtig.
So, und ansonsten, whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
Jetzt übrigens alles auf GitHub ist, kann man sich angucken.
Ich müsste das wirklich mal kommentieren, dass ich selbst noch verstehen würde, was da eigentlich passiert.
Also, oh my zisch, mag ich gar nicht.
Ich habe mir das selbst customised und ich meine, man sieht ja hier, man sieht ja hier, ein paar zusätzliche Sachen habe ich noch drin.
Ja, zum Beispiel Auto-Suggestions und Syntax-Highlighting.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ihr seht ja, wenn ich hier irgendwie was schreibe, so hier, ne, also while, true, Echo, 1, 2, 3, dann wird das Syntax-Highlighted.
Das kommt von dem Syntax-Highlight-Plug.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch, gerade wenn so ein paar Eins-Teile-Dinger ganz mal schnell auf der Shell-Zusammenskript, das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Und dann habe ich noch Auto-Completion.
Auto-Completion ist das, was ihr jetzt hier hinten seht.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt hier sage LSLA und dann sagt der hier, du hast das letzte Mal dieses Kommando verwendet, willst du nicht jetzt wieder das gleiche hinten dran machen?
Dann kann ich sagen, okay, ja, ich accepte die Auto-Completion und drücke eine Taste und dann macht das gleiche nochmal.
Das sind aber eigentlich so die einzigen zwei Dinger, die ich da an Plugins noch habe.
Ja, aber genug zu meiner Shell, ja.
Doc, was, Documenso, kenne ich nicht.
Oh, das klingt nach Zertifikats-Signing-Gedöns, kenne ich nicht.
Ne, sagt mir nix.
Virtual Box is Paints, vor allem mit Windows.
Das macht aber KVM, oder?
Nutzt das nicht KVM unter der Haube?
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, Windows Terminal ist ja auch Schrott ohne Ende.
Hyper-Schrott, ey.
So, machen wir das hier mal wieder zu.
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Aber ein bisschen.
Zeit-Tracking muss sein.
Ich bin heute am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt vorbeigelaufen, ja.
Ist ja, ist ja eigentlich nix Besonderes.
Ich bin es ja mittlerweile gewöhnt, aber ich hatte heute ein bisschen mehr Zeit.
Ich bin zur vollen Stunde rausgelaufen und dementsprechend hatte ich quasi fünf Minuten länger Zeit als sonst.
Bin ich auch ein bisschen langsamer gelaufen und Leute, was da mittlerweile für Leute rumstehen, Alter.
Ich meine, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof war schon immer zwischen MonKS und KeckWait, was da rumstand.
Also schon immer zwischen Fürchten und Wundern und Warten, dass irgendwas passiert.
Also, aber mittlerweile, ey.
Komme ich, wo die...
Kommen die alle her, die Leute, die da im Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof stehen?
Ist das so Leute, die es überhaupt gibt?
Also, ich bin es ja mittlerweile gewohnt.
Was, was ganz merkwürdig ist, auf dem Weg zum Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, das ist so ein neues Ding.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, woran das liegt.
Hängen jetzt total viele Leute rum, die einen immer angucken und grüßen.
Die sagen immer, hallo, hallo oder alles klar, alles klar oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die mit dir ins Gespräch kommen.
Wollen, um dir irgendwelche Drogen zu verkaufen.
Oder wenn du stehen bleibst, raubt dich einer von hinten aus oder so.
Aber dieses an, dieses, dieses so von der Seite angesprochen werden, so, so, so, das ist so ganz merkwürdig.
Das gab es früher die ganze Zeit nicht.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, ich finde, das Klientelamt Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, falls man das so nennen kann.
Das Klientelamt Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof hat sich ein bisschen gewandelt.
Und es gibt immer noch...
Gefühlt sehr viele Drogenabhängige und Leute, die da irgendwie in der Ecke rumgammeln und so.
Aber, was so die letzten Jahre über zugenommen hat, ist, wie beschreibe ich denn die Leute am besten?
Also ich kenne die ja nicht, ich kann die ja nur optisch, optisch beschreiben.
Kennt ihr dieses Meme mit dem einen Film mit Tom Hanks, wo er mit dem Terroristen auf dem Schiff ist und der, der, der...
Moment.
Da gibt es doch dieses eine Bild mit diesem Tom Hanks.
Diesem Look-at-me-Typ.
Look-at-me.
Ja.
Moment.
Copy-Image-Address.
What the fuck?
Warum kann ich nicht...
Warum kopiert das nicht die Image-Address?
Wahnsinn.
So.
So sehen gefühlt 90% der Leute am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof mittlerweile aus.
Und die gucken dich genauso an wie der Typ.
Und also, das hat sich schon ein bisschen gewandelt die letzten Jahre über.
Also auf dem Weg zum Hauptbahnhof.
Das hat sich die letzten Jahre über schon gewandelt.
Weg von einfach nur, ja, Gehirn kaputt in der Ecke liegend zu solchen Leuten.
Aber die sehen, die sehen genauso aus wie der Typ auf dem Bild Richtung Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Ja, das wäre mir auch aufgefallen, als ich aber ein bisschen langsamer langgelaufen bin.
Das hat sich, hat sich gewandelt auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dafür musst du dir...
Dafür eine Sache ist tatsächlich besser geworden am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Es liegen weniger Spritzen rum.
Es könnte jetzt auch liegen, dass die vielleicht mehr aufräumen oder so, weiß ich.
Aber insgesamt liegen weniger Spritzen und solche, solche Geschichten rum.
Also, gerade früher, ich weiß noch, wo ich klein war, war ich öfters mit meinem Vater mal am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Da sind wir ja immer, ich bin früher, als ich, als ich klein war, bin ich mega gerne U-Bahn gefahren.
Und da musste mein Vater manchmal mit mir da im Kreis mit der U-Bahn fahren und so.
Da war, da war, da war richtig so Spritzen und Nadeln überall und sowas.
War, war später immer noch, ja, hatte man immer noch, musste man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Aber da ist, da, da siehst du jetzt kaum noch was, muss man.
Das, das ist tatsächlich besser geworden am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Dortmund Haupt, Dortmund Hauptbahnhof war ich noch nie.
Also, der letzte Bahnhof, wo mir aufgefallen ist, wo ich auch erst mich direkt an Frankfurt erinnert,
gefühlt habe, ist Berlin.
Berlin Hauptbahnhof.
Da, da habe ich mich überhaupt nicht zurechtgefunden.
Da bin ich rausgegangen und das Erste, was passiert ist, irgendein, ja, keine Ahnung, ich sage jetzt mal Penner,
sah zumindest so aus, hat mir, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe die Tür aufgemacht.
Da kam mir der Typ entgegen, die, die eiern ja immer so ein bisschen rum und hustet mir voll ins Gesicht.
Da habe ich gesagt, ey, ist ja wieder heim, Alter, ist wieder heim.
Aber ansonsten ist es natürlich schon etwas netter.
Also, Berlin am Hauptbahnhof, zumindest an der einen Seite, wo ich raus bin, weil da ist ziemlich viel offene, offene Sicht und ein bisschen, ein bisschen Grün, Grünfläche.
Und wenn man von da weiterläuft, kommt man dann auch am Reichstag vorbei und Brandenburger Tor.
Also im Prinzip alles, was man in Berlin sehen will, kann man sich vom Hauptbahnhof, vom Hauptbahnhof angucken innerhalb von 20 Minuten und dann fährt man wieder weg.
Dann ist man, dann ist gut, genug Kulturprogramm.
Ja, wie gesagt, es ist in den letzten Jahren ist das mit Nadeln und solchen.
Drogengeschichten am Hauptbahnhof viel besser geworden.
Dafür hast du jetzt so Typen, wie ich dir gerade gezeigt habe, da in Massen stehen.
Nicht im Hauptbahnhof und im Hauptbahnhof siehst du eh so gut wie nichts, seitdem es da sehr viel Polizeipräsenz und Bahn Security Präsenz gibt.
Also im Hauptbahnhof selber ist so gut wie gar nichts.
Du hast ein paar fertige Leute rumirren oftmals, aber das war's ja manchmal ganz selten hast du, wenn du sehr früh da bist, irgendwie.
Ein Typ in einem kaputten Schaufenster liegen oder sowas.
Aber es ist kaum was.
An's trinken erinnern, exzellent.
Also im Hauptbahnhof selbst, das ist ja auch eines der Lieblingsfragen auf Reddit irgendwie.
Ist es sicher am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof?
Ja, es ist sicher, wenn man da aussteigen, umsteigen muss, innen drin ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Draußen ist es kein brasilianischer Slum oder so, das ist schon okay.
Aber sonderlich angenehm ist es dort trotzdem nicht.
Ja und wenn man mal in die Seitenstraße geht vom Hauptbahnhof, dann ist das schon okay.
Da ist halt, da ist halt mehr Elend als gefährlich, so richtig.
Spreizon
Es gibt ja sogar Führungen durch das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Weiß echt nicht, was man sich da groß angucken will, so die dro--, die, die, die..
Wie heißt das?
Es gibt ja sogar Führungen durch das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Weiß echt nicht, was man sich da groß angucken will, so die dro--, die, die, die, wie heißt das?
Uff, was bin ich hier auf?
Uff.
Nicht Drogenausgabestationen, sondern so diese Ersatzdrogenausgabestationen oder was.
Wenn man sich da anguckt bei der Führung durchs Bahnhofsviertel.
Wie viele Tage derzeit im Homeoffice?
Also, ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche, davon drei Tage Homeoffice, ein Tag vor Ort.
Im Durchschnitt, ja.
Kommt sicherlich irgendwann auch mal vor, weil ich zwei Tage da bin.
Und es kommt sicherlich auch mal vor, dass ich alle Tage daheim bin.
Aber im Durchschnitt ist es so, vier Tage arbeiten, davon drei Tage Homeoffice, ein Tag vor Ort.
Heute war ich übrigens vor Ort.
Hätte das gedacht, nachdem ich über die Bahn flamen musste.
Die haben jetzt ein neues geiles Feature in der Bahn-App.
Man sieht alte Verbindungen nicht mehr richtig.
Also alte Verbindungen sind Verbindungen, von denen die Bahn denkt, dass sie schon angekommen sind.
Schwinden einfach.
Dass man nicht mal nachgucken kann.
Dass er Zugverspätung hatte.
Ich wollte heute Morgen screenshotten, dass sie es geschafft haben, auf eine 3-Minuten-Verbindung über 11 Minuten Verspätung zu bekommen.
Also die Verbindung hat quasi drei- bis vierfach so lange gedauert.
Und dann habe ich den Zug nicht erwischt, musste einen anderen Zug fahren.
Ja.
Also, im Regionalexpress am Hauptbahnhof, was mir da öfters auffällt, also bekifft der Typ, keine Ahnung.
Aber was mir da öfters auffällt, sind die Typen, die kennt ihr vielleicht auch, die am Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof einsteigen.
Und durch den Zug laufen.
Früher sind die rumgelaufen, ja.
Kennt ihr ja noch so von früher, so nach dem Motto, ah, ob man mal einen Euro hat und sowas.
Heute ist das, heute ist das, ähm, trickreicher.
Heute steigen die in den Zug ein und sagen, oh, sie müssen dringend nach Fulda, ihre Tochter ist krank.
Ob man ihr Geld für ein Ticket hat und sowas.
Und ich habe schon gesehen, dass Leute denen Geld gegeben haben.
Und wenigstens so zu tun und den Schein zu wahren, dass das stimmt.
Was die Leute erzählen.
Aber nein, der ist quasi einfach zum nächsten Platz gegangen, hat die gleiche Story wiedererzählt.
Der ist nicht etwa ein Abteil weiter, dass der Typ, der ihm Geld gegeben hat, wenigstens nicht checkt, dass er ihm Scheiße erzählt hat.
Nee, der ist einfach direkt zum nächsten gegangen und hat gesagt, meine Tochter ist im Krankenhaus in Fulda, ich bin total fertig, ich muss dahin, ich habe kein Geld.
Ja, das ist das High Performer Grindset Mindset.
Das lernt man bestimmt in der Gruppe, ja.
Leute belästigen im Zug in Frankfurt, hoppala.
Hast du Empfehlungen fürs Essen gehen, wenn ich mal wieder länger umstehe?
Ich habe tatsächlich, was ich sehr nice finde in Frankfurt, habe ich letztens erst entdeckt.
Also, entdeckt, mir hat das einer empfohlen, da war ich da, fand ich gut.
Wenn man auf sowas steht hier, Frankfurt, Korean Fried Chicken.
Und zwar...
Cheeking.
Cheeking City.
Richtig nice.
Ja, wer das mit Pommes frites futtert, dem ist eh nicht zu helfen.
Ja.
Mega nice.
Leider sieht man das ja alles immer nur mit Pommes frites.
So hier, ja, so sieht das aus.
Richtig nice.
Also, das ist nicht die, also, wenn ihr euch das normale bestellt, ist die Portion größer.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich Mittagsmenü mit was zu trinken noch dabei.
Schmeckt richtig nice.
Warum es da zwei Stück Melone gibt, verstehe ich allerdings auch nicht.
Ja.
Aber das ist, das ist nice.
Das ist auch um die Ecke vom Hauptbahnhof.
Und Mittagsmenü, Mittagsmenü kostet nur 12 Euro.
Vor ein paar Jahren wäre das übelst teuer gewesen, aber mittlerweile ist 12 Euro echt ganz okay.
Ja.
Also, das kann ich empfehlen, das schmeckt gut.
Korean Fried Chicken.
Und die sind sehr schnell.
Du setzt dich rein, bestellst, fünf Minuten später hast du dein Essen.
Oder zehn Minuten später.
Also, die sind wirklich sehr zackig.
Fünf bis zehn Minuten.
Und die Hähnchen haben keine Knochen drin.
Also, du kannst einfach weg, weg spachteln.
Servus, was hältst du von Umschulung?
Ich habe nie eine Umschulung gemacht.
Ich persönlich finde die Möglichkeit nicht verkehrt.
Man muss aber sagen, dass gerade die Arbeitsamtsschulungen, habe ich teilweise den Eindruck,
die versuchen alles und jeden auf, ja, alles und jedes umzuschulen.
Und es ist einfach so, du kannst nicht jeden, der keinen Job findet, zum Fachinformatiker umschulen.
Für manche Leute ist das einfach nichts.
Und das soll jetzt nicht heißen, ey, das ist besser oder so.
Für mich wären viele andere Berufe auch nichts.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht, keine Ahnung, Werner, der mit Technik gar nichts zu tun hat
und sein ganzes Leben im Bergwerk gearbeitet hat, um jetzt mal übertrieben was zu sagen,
den kannst du nicht zum Physio umschulen.
Kannst du schon, wenn er sich dafür interessiert.
Und auch da privaten Interessen und allem hat.
Aber wenn er es nicht macht, dann hat er es ja auch keinen Sinn.
Mach mal einen Umschulung.
Warum, dass ich dann endlich was mit Holz arbeiten kann oder wie?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, genau sowas meine ich.
Genau sowas meine ich, ja.
Ja.
Leute, die über Schreibmaschinen noch nicht rausgekommen sind
und wohlgemerkt auch keinerlei Interesse,
daran haben,
die werden dann Physio umgeschult.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen
Painstamp.
Ja gut, das habe ich ja auch schon öfters erzählt.
Das war bei mir ja nicht anders.
Chat, gut, dass ihr...
Es hat alles seine Vorteile.
Überlegt euch mal, die Sekretärin hat sich irgendwie
Ransomware eingefangen und
der zentrale Pfeilschall wird verschlüsselt.
Nix geht mehr.
Sein Onkel tippt immer noch Zeug auf der Schreibmaschine.
Manchmal ist analoge Technik
vielleicht doch nicht so gut.
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Und danach kann er das Ganze noch per Fax schicken.
Also komplette Firma noch handlungsfähig,
nur weil noch eine Schreibmaschine
und ein Faxgerät am Start ist.
Es ist eh der Witz, dass du in Deutschland
auch für einige Sachen Faxgeräte zwingend brauchst.
Und gerade so Sachen wie,
dass du das rechtlich,
verbindlich was zugestellt wurde und sowas,
ist ja viel klarer geregelt bei einem Fax
als beispielsweise
bei einer E-Mail.
Auch im Jahr 2024 noch.
Ja, heute
ein bisschen Laberstream.
Ich bin ja froh, dass mich keiner bisher gefragt hat.
Max, was machen wir heute?
Hätte ich nämlich sagen müssen, nix.
Ich schwätze ein bisschen vor mich hin.
Was Faxlizenzen erneuert?
Für Fax braucht man keine Lizenz.
Was ist älter, E-Mail oder Fax?
Das ist so eine Frage,
wo jeder normalerweise drauf antworten würde,
Fax.
Aber,
wenn man alles damit,
reinrechnet so,
auch vielleicht so die theoretischen
Überlegungen für E-Mail und sowas,
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich würde trotzdem sagen,
Fax ist auf jeden Fall älter.
Es müsste allgemein ein bisschen weniger Bürokratie
geben. Das wäre schon nice.
Digitales oder analoges Fax?
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es sowas wie digitales Fax gibt.
Ich dachte, dass selbst digitales Fax
eigentlich nur ein emuliertes analoges Fax ist.
Aber...
...
PiaChamp hat keine Issues.
Das sind
Skill Issues der Anwender.
Wieso?
Gibt es da wieder was Neues?
Ups.
Ich müsste da echt mal dran
und ein paar grundlegende Sachen umbauen,
weil vieles ist gar nicht möglich
von dem, wie ich es gebaut habe.
Beispielsweise, wenn du zwei Autos hast
bei einem unterschiedlichen Hersteller,
geht das Ganze damit schon mal nicht.
Und da gibt es tatsächlich,
Einige, sogar welche, die das schon auf GitHub geschrieben haben
Ja, beispielsweise irgendwelche Amis, die einen Fiat haben
Fiat Elektroauto
Und dann auch irgendeinen Ram Truck oder sowas
Und das kannst du aktuell mit dem Android nicht machen
Ich müsste echt
Boah, ich bin aber so faul gerade da dran weiterzubasteln
Vielleicht wäre ich motivierter, wenn irgendjemand Bock drauf hätte mitzumachen
Aber ich bin sehr unzuverlässig
Rewrite in Rust
Damit das nicht mehr passiert
Wie?
Damit was nicht mehr passiert?
Dass ich mir eine blöde Anwendungsarchitektur ausdenke
Oder dass ich keinen Bock mehr habe
Ich glaube, vor beidem kann mich Rust nur schwer beschützen
Moin Max, wie läuft das Runners Game?
Ja, ich war vorhin gerade wieder eine Runde Rennen
Allerdings heute hat mein Trainingsplan gesagt
37 Minuten Base Run
Also
Lahm und nicht so lang
Lahm, je nachdem wie man es nennt, ja
7 Minuten 5 pro Kilometer
Das ist für den einen oder anderen relativ schnell
Für manch anderen ist das abgrundtief langsam
Kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an
Schon mal ein Runners
Ne, noch nie, noch nie
Ich meine, nicht, dass mir nicht schon mal die Gelenke wehgetan hätten oder sowas, ja
Aber das hatte ich, das hatte ich noch nie
Was ich, was ich habe, wenn ich es übertrage
Was ich, was ich schreibe ist
Gerade wenn ich zu schnell gerannt bin und dann
Mal
Nächsten Tag auch zu viel gemacht habe
Ist, dass es eine Weile dauert
Bis mir mein Schienbein nicht mehr weh tut
Ja, ich meine, ich bin immer noch nicht der Leichteste
Mir tut dann relativ schnell
Mal das Schienbein weh
Aber das geht dann auch wieder weg
Also, ne, hatte ich das Problem, hatte ich noch nicht
Rust hilft bei allem
Ja, Rust hilft bei allem dafür
Hilft vor allem dafür, sich geil zu finden
Weil man Rust verwendet
Bundesnetzagentur sucht neuen Faxanbieter
Okay, das war Januar letztes Jahr
Lul
Kannst du mal das reviewen
Bei der Enformversicherung
Ha, da kenne ich sogar jemanden, der da arbeitet
Gucken, welches Team das ist
Steht nicht da, oder?
Ist das da?
Keine Ahnung
Also
Ja, da kenne ich einen
Der dort arbeitet
Ehemaliger Kollege
Der ist da hingewechselt
Muskellieg? Gab es schon öfters
Ja, so muss das sein
Ähm, okay
Ich kann mal reingucken, ja
Willst du dich da bewerben, oder?
Oder wie?
Herr Darkseid
Zeig mal, ja
Wir sind versichert, okay, bla bla bla
Was suchen sie denn überhaupt?
DevOps Engineer
MWD
Nee, komm nicht
Also, wie gesagt
Ich kenne einen, der dort arbeitet
Ob das jetzt gleiche Zeug ist, keine Ahnung
Die sind aber auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht
Was ich gehört habe
In ihrer Rolle unterstützen sie als Multiplikator
MWD
Du musst mit besonders vielen Leuten kompatibel sein
Oder wie?
Multiplikator DevSecOpsTeam
DevSecWinBisOps
Warum nicht nur mehr?
DevSecOps Teams dabei, ihren Reifegrad zu optimieren, die Prinzipien von DevSecOps zu verstehen
und diese in der Praxis umzusetzen.
Das hier leuchtet mir ja noch ein.
Die meinen mit Reifegrad eher sowas wie Kenntnisstand, oder?
Sowas wie Skill-Level. Meinen die sowas wie Skill-Level damit?
Okay, das ist schon so kompliziert geschrieben, dass ich meine, ein Problem hat die Stellenanzeige überhaupt zu checken.
Oder meinen die den Reifegrad ihrer Anwendung zu... whatever, keine Ahnung.
Das hätte man auch ein bisschen klarer schreiben können, was jetzt eigentlich Sache ist.
Konkret begleiten sie unterschiedliche Teams im Rahmen der DevSecOps-Transformation von Mainframe
und Cloud-Entwicklern bis zur Infrastruktur-Bereitsteller.
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit, ich hoffe aber diagonal, zu verbessern.
Übrigens, warum überhaupt Cloud?
Scaler, Leute. Hyperscaler.
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit zu verbessern, tragen sie maßgeblich zur Automatisierung in den fachlichen Arzt...
What?
Okay, also ich hatte schon Probleme bei dem ersten Satz.
Aber was soll denn das bedeuten?
Um die Effizienz und Skalierbarkeit...
Bis hierhin verstehe ich es ja noch, weil hier ein Punkt ist okay.
Tragen sie maßgeblich zur Automatisierung in den fachlichen Arzt bei?
Ich kenne Warts, das ist so ein Zombiespiel.
Okay, wir fragen DuckDuckGo.
Was bedeutet das in einer Stellenanzeige?
Ach, die meinen damit sowas...
Agile Release Train.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ja, das würde allerdings zu DevOps Engineer passen.
Siehst du, nicht mal Chat-GPT weiß, was das damit eigentlich auf sich hat.
F-Ops 8.
Agile Release Train.
What the fuck?
Oh Mann.
Ah, the primary value delivery construct in SAFE.
Ah ja, klar.
Scalable Agile Framework, oder?
Heißt das?
SAFE.
Sorry, sorry.
Ah, Scaled Agile Framework.
Fast.
Ganzer Bullshit.
Mit Krempel da, man.
Äh, eine Güte.
Können wir uns nicht einfach drauf beschränken, das zu machen, was eigentlich die Essenz von Agile ist?
Nämlich, möglichst viel Manager-Kram von Entwicklern fernhalten.
Das ist die Essenz von Agile.
Entwickler ihren Job machen zu lassen und sich nicht den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchem Management und Orga-Kram auseinandersetzen zu müssen.
Und das denkt nicht nur ich mir.
Das sagt einer der Mitgründer, Miterfinder dieser ganzen Sache.
Und nicht mit dem ganzen Zeug.
Da gibt's ja jeden Tag was Neues, Mann.
So ganz sinnlos sind Manager ja nicht, Chat.
Ja, ab und zu, gerade wenn sie was können, was natürlich nicht so einfach ist, aber, äh, also was, wo es nicht so viele gibt, aber die ist schon nicht verkehrt, ja, wenn du ein paar Leute hast, die gut organisieren können.
Und vor allem sind Manager dafür da, unter anderem Probleme aus dem Weg zu schaffen und nicht, äh, sollten nicht mehr Probleme...
...schaffen, als sie lösen, so, ne?
Zumindest ist da eines der Hauptgedanken von Agile, dass Entwickler eigenständig entwickeln können, ohne sich tagtäglich mit irgendwelchen, äh, Product-Ownern, Managern und sonst was auseinanderzusetzen.
Das ist der Sinn von, also eines der Hauptziele von Agile.
So, okay.
Also, hier wär ich schon mal lost gewesen.
Keine Ahnung, was sie da gewollt hätten.
Ich weiß, dass es, äh, dass es wahrscheinlich Agile-Release-Trains sind.
Ähm.
Mit, äh...
Mit, mit, der einzige Punkt ist, ich hab bis jetzt keine Ahnung, was eigentlich Agile-Release-Trains sind.
Außer, dass es das Primary Value Delivering Construct in SAFe ist.
Dafür wissen wir jetzt natürlich auch sofort Bescheid, ja?
Okay.
Aber dann ergibt's zumindest Sinn im Kontext von einem DevOps-Engineer.
Weiterhin erarbeiten sie Best Practices und etablieren Standards gemeinsam mit den Teams oder Com...
...oder Communities of Practice?
Warum muss man jedem Kram irgendeinen bescheuerten Namen geben?
Was sollen bitteschön Communities of Practice sein?
Alter!
Ist das auch SAFe?
Ja, klar!
Was sonst?
Alter!
Das ist ja grausam!
Das ist zum Hyperskalieren des, des, des Grindset Mindsets, ja.
Communities of Practice.
Cops!
Vielleicht auch eine etwas ungünstige Abkürzung, oder?
Anzeige ist raus!
Communities of Cops are organized groups of people with a common interest in a specific technical or business...
Ah, Moment!
Ist das das, was bei anderen Agile-Dingern als Tribes and...
Fuck, ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Agile Tribes...
Tribes and...
Ja.
Dieses ganze Agile-Zeug nimmt einfach echt über an!
Jeder denkt sich irgendeinen eigenen Scheiß aus, Mann!
Agile Scaling...
Tribes, Squads, Chapters and Guilds!
Alter, was ein Shit!
Ja, Squads, danach hab ich gesucht, Mann, ey.
Wahnsinn, Alter.
Aber die sind richtig, richtig agil, hier auf jeden Fall.
Agil, ja, auf jeden Fall!
Agil, auf jeden Fall!
Oh, Mann!
Agil, ja, auf jeden Fall!
Beim Fördern des Bewusstseins für Sicherheitsaspekte und Compliance...
Oh, Mann!
Gut!
Ja, wir sind hier bei einer Versicherung.
Da sind ein paar so was immer, da sind die ganz, ganz scharf drauf.
Gut!
Ja, wir sind hier bei einer Versicherung.
Da sind ein paar so was immer, da sind die ganz, ganz scharf drauf.
In der Entwicklung und dem Betrieb von Anwendungen vertrauen wir auf ihr Engagement.
Okay.
Hey, wenigstens war ein Satz, den ich verstehe.
Nee, hab ich nicht geguckt.
geguckt das durchführen von workshops zu devsec ops prozessen und richtigen sowie
das beraten und unterstützen der teams und hoffentlich auch der community soft
practice ja beim umsetzen von devsec ops praktiken runden die aufgaben fällt ab
ok das problem bei dieser stellenanzeige was ich sehe ist nicht dass das jetzt
irgendwie ein schlechter laden wäre oder so das kann ich nicht beurteilen
zumindest das was ich gehört habe von meinem kollegen arbeit der fenster
eigentlich ziemlich gut also die scheinen nicht schlecht zu sein
ich habe das problem mit der stellenanzeige dass ich die hälfte der
stellenanzeige ok sagen wir mal ein drittel der stellenanzeige schon mal
gar nicht genau verstehe was die eigentlich von mir wollte würde mir die
serie gefallen ja wahrscheinlich ich habe bestimmt schon die einen oder
anderen ausschnitte gesehen ich kenne das ich kenne dass ich habe da schon ein
paar aussteller
draußen
ausgesehen ist das haben die da auch eine haben die da auch eine inder im
team wenn ja dann kenne ich das habe ich ein paar ausschnitte davon schon mal
gesehen ja da habe ich schon ein paar ausschnitte von gesehen ja ja das könnte
mir durchaus gefallen wobei ich so komme die sachen ich habe das problem dass die
die meisten sachen die unterkommen die so laufen nicht lustig finde ich kann
mir beispielsweise auch die office nicht angucken dass das ist einfach nur ultra
für mich und unangenehm okay was wie geht es denn hier weiter ich weiß dass das
nicht auf grün gemacht wie gesagt ich habe schon ein paar ausschnitte gesehen
it kraut oder wie das hieß das it kraut märkte kraut f4 f4 try to turn it off
and on again ja ja das ist auch so ein ding was übelst gefeiert wird von vielen
ich konnte der sache auch nichts abgewinnen neues firebase video der typ
heißt feier schippe
fallschirm
falls du den meinst nicht firebase firebase ist das cloud gedöns feier schipp ist
firebase ist das cloud gedönsip ist der youtube channel so also was suchen er sonst noch
anforderung ok die übliche relevante berufserfahrung im dephob und
umfeld ja das wäre es schon sinnvoll fachwissen rund um lexicon
absoluten technologien ci cdi monitoring security orchestration automatisierung sowie
kultur technologie in worten wie systematisch and Hobly und rucksack ex ね
Kultur und Zusammenarbeit, das passt doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht zu dieser Aufzählung jetzt dabei, ja, das eine sind wirklich knallhart, sagen wir mal so Technik-Sachen und die Kultur, das hat irgendwas mit dem jeweiligen Unternehmen zu tun, das kannst du gar nicht wissen, bevor du da gewesen bist, ja, und dass man vielleicht auch mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten können sollte, so ein bisschen Soft-Skill-mäßig, wie man das so schön nennt, ja, gut, das verstehe ich,
aber das passt in die Aufzählung hier nicht rein, Erfahrung in der Zusammenarbeit mit Entwicklern und Betrieben, das finde ich tatsächlich cool, dass das drinne steht, ja, das ist als DevOps-Engineer tatsächlich recht wichtig, dass man bei beiden Seiten gut kann, Problemlösungsorientierung, Selbstorganisation und Kommunikation sowie Präsentationsstärke, gepaart mit der Fähigkeit, komplexe Konzepte, okay, ja, fließend Deutsch, idealerweise Schrift und Schrift, unser Angebot, führen Einsatz,
jetzt kommt wieder ein Satz, ey,
für die abwechslungsreiche Stelle suchen wir ein offenes Kommunikationstalent mit Fokus auf Enabling und Hickchen gesetzt quasi, dann ist es Enabled, Checkbox, ist sowohl technisch noch als auch kreative Lösung, die Stelle bietet zudem viel Gestaltung, sie erwartet ein starkes Team, das auf mittelfristig auch weiterhin zum Produkt-Owner bzw. SAE Service, was ist ein SAE, Side-Rail, ne,
äh,
nein,
nehmen wir eine Ahnung,
ne, das passt hier nicht wirklich drunter, unser Angebot, führen Einsatz, oder,
passt thematisch nicht, nicht dazu,
manchmal wäre es echt sinnvoll, wenn man die Sachen ausschreibt, oder,
meine, die Senior, ne,
Senior-Anwendungsentwickler vielleicht,
hä,
whatever,
wie sehen wir,
Benefits, Homeoffice,
ja, das habe ich tatsächlich gehört, dass das,
dort recht gut funktioniert,
Senior-Alles-Enabler, ja,
ähm,
ach, da ist unsere 13,
ok, also,
aufgrund meiner Erfahrung,
mit meinem Ex-Kolleg,
der dort arbeitet,
kann ich sagen, der Laden ist nicht schlecht,
die Stellenanzeige ist,
so semi-nice,
aber, wenn sich ein Kollege von dir dort bewerben will,
dann,
dann soll er sich bewerben,
der Laden ist nicht verkehrt, von allem, was ich gehört habe,
die Stellenanzeige ist halt, pepega, irgendwo,
wisst ihr, was ich für einen Eindruck habe, bei der Stellenanzeige,
dass es eine Stellenanzeige ist,
die intern geschaltet wurde,
die für interne Besetzung geschrieben wurde,
und man hat vergessen,
als man keinen gefunden hat,
diese Stellenanzeige umzuschreiben,
für nicht interne Leute,
dass die auch verstehen,
was die eigentlich haben wollen,
so wirkt das ein bisschen auf mich,
ja,
Max, wie findest du Scrum,
richtig gemacht, ist das eine gute Sache,
aber es wird selten richtig,
äh, wird selten, äh,
gut gemacht,
es artet eher in irgend so eine Glaubenssache aus,
so nach dem Motto, ok,
wenn wir uns jetzt,
eine Viertelstunde am Tag in Kreis stellen,
ohne dass man sich dabei hinsetzt,
sind wir auf einmal agil und viel produktiver,
und solche Dinger,
das macht dann natürlich keinen Sinn,
wie gesagt,
ich finde die, die Grund, den Grundgedanken,
dahinter dieser ganzen Agile Sache steckt,
oder zumindest das, was auch einer der Mitunterzeichner,
dieses ursprünglichen agilen Manifests und sowas,
ja,
was der sagt ist,
und das, das finde ich tatsächlich gut,
dass,
eines seiner Motivationsgründe für diese ganze Agilitätssache war,
dass sich Entwickler weniger direkt mit dem Management auseinandersetzen,
müssen,
und das finde ich sinnvoll,
weil wenn du den ganzen Tag,
damit beschäftigt bist,
hier, können wir das so machen,
ach nee, ich habe es mal,
so,
ah, ich habe mit dem gesprochen,
da musst du es so,
da kriegst du es nicht so auf die Reihe,
oder ah, jetzt müssen sie mal ganz schnell gucken,
weil hier ist irgendwas,
Management-Orgasachen von den Entwicklern fernhalten,
und trotzdem den Leuten Einfluss nehmen,
also Einflussmöglichkeiten geben,
auf das Projekt,
weil letztendlich bezahlen die es ja auch,
dafür ist,
das, das ist ein guter Ansatz,
wie das teilweise umgesetzt wird,
und dass das oftmals auch schon tatsächlich so ein bisschen in,
so eine Glaubensfrage ausartet,
das finde ich dann wieder bescheuert.
Wisst ihr, was ich lustig finde?
Die ganzen Beratungsunternehmen,
haben ja ein Bullshit, Bullshit-Bingo drauf,
und die verkaufen,
also,
wie soll ich sagen,
die haben halt auch keine wirkliche Ahnung,
was sie da so treiben,
sondern die können gut verkaufen,
und zwar,
wo ich mal ein Beispiel dazu bringe,
in dem letzten Unternehmen,
wo ich gearbeitet habe,
hat uns irgendein Beratungsunternehmen,
wollte uns verkaufen,
also, da ging es ja darum so,
wie soll das hier mit Prozessen,
und Strukturen,
wie soll das alles neu ausgerichtet werden,
ja, da haben die sich das von irgendeinem Beratungsunternehmen,
so ein, wie nennt man das,
so ein Konzept erarbeiten lassen,
und da stand unter anderem drinnen,
ich muss jetzt aufpassen,
dass ich nichts,
dass ich das doch richtig zusammenkriege,
in diesem Konzept stand unter anderem drinnen,
ähm,
mehr in Stellen denken,
als in Personen,
so,
und in dem Unternehmen, wo ich jetzt bin,
die haben auch so ein,
auch so ein Beratungsunternehmen am Start,
und dort,
das Beratungsunternehmen sagt,
ja,
eher,
äh,
nee, wie haben die gesagt,
eher Köpfe als Stellen,
oder sowas,
das ist halt,
die verkaufen immer das,
was gerade nicht da ist,
um ihren Kram verkaufen zu können,
also das allerwichtigste,
aus meiner Sicht,
ist, dass man Leute hat,
die wissen, was sie machen,
in ihrem jeweiligen Bereich,
und das ist deutlich weniger verbreitet,
als man denkt,
ich habe euch ja vom,
vom,
von meinem letzten Job erzählt,
vom Java-Entwickler,
der nicht Java programmieren konnte,
und vom,
äh,
Change-Koordinator,
der keine Changes koordinieren wollte,
und sowas,
wir sind alle,
ab und zu mal Low-Performer,
außer die mit dem richtigen
Crimeset-Mindset natürlich,
ja,
die in der Gruppe sind,
die nicht,
aber,
ich finde es nicht schlimm,
wenn Leute es auch mal ruhig angehen lassen,
was ich viel entscheidender finde,
ist,
dass die Sachen,
die sie machen,
durchdacht sind,
und,
mir ist es lieber,
einer ist kein,
wie heißt das,
ja doch,
hier,
10 Times Developer,
oder,
whatever,
ja,
mir ist das lieber,
einer ist faul,
und,
also,
ich spreche da aus Erfahrung,
ja,
mir ist es lieber,
jemand ist faul,
aber das,
was rauskommt,
funktioniert,
und,
bei faulen Leuten,
ist die,
Chance,
dass es was rauskommt,
wenn sie was rauskommt,
und,
bei faulen Leuten,
ist die,
Chance,
dass es was rauskommt,
wenn sie was gemacht haben,
dass es funktioniert,
höher,
weil,
die wollen sich ja nie wieder,
damit beschäftigen müssen,
da gibt es sogar,
Untersuchungen zu,
also,
faule Leute,
sind richtig gut da drin,
Sachen überlegt,
um zu,
obwohl sie faul sind,
die finden genau,
die richtige Balance,
aus,
Einsatz,
und,
es muss aber,
gut sein,
dass ich mich danach,
nie wieder,
damit beschäftigen muss,
ja,
und,
sobald,
sobald du anfängst,
natürlich,
zu überlasten,
da kommt nichts gescheites,
mehr raus,
ich,
ich habe mal,
einen Vortrag gesehen,
das habe ich euch,
glaube ich,
schon mal gezeigt,
aber,
ich habe mal,
einen Vortrag gesehen,
das fand ich,
echt gut gemacht,
und zwar,
der hat so eine Tabelle gemalt,
ich,
bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das überhaupt,
aus dem Kopf,
noch zusammenkriege,
ja,
der hat,
der hatte irgendwie,
so eine Tabelle gemalt,
und zwar,
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich es richtig,
hat,
keine Ahnung,
und dann gab es noch,
irgendwie,
ja,
meine,
meine Tabellen-Skills,
sind,
sind ganz,
ganz toll,
und dann gab es noch,
ähm,
ja,
keine Ahnung,
super motiviert,
und,
dann gab es noch,
irgendwie,
ja,
unmotiviert,
so,
ich,
ich glaube,
so war das,
und dann meinte er so,
ey,
was sind,
eigentlich,
Mitarbeiter,
die man haben möchte,
und,
ja,
klar,
jemand,
der Ahnung hat,
super motiviert ist,
und,
super krassen,
Arbeits-Output hat,
das sind,
so die,
ähm,
ja,
wie nennt man das,
so die,
die,
heraus,
so herausstechende Leute,
da gibt es nicht,
so viele von,
aber,
die muss man sich warm halten,
so,
das sind so quasi,
die,
wie,
wie hat man bei,
zu Ruby-Zeiten früher gesagt,
die Rockstar-Developer,
ne,
aber,
die muss man sich warm halten,
also,
die will man,
die will man auf jeden Fall haben,
ja,
die,
die will man,
die will man auf jeden Fall haben,
hat Ahnung,
und ist unmotiviert,
den will man auch haben,
ähm,
weil,
unmotivierte Leute,
beziehungsweise,
unmotiviert ist,
aber,
wir,
das trifft es in dem Fall,
besser,
als unmotiviert,
faul,
okay,
faule Leute,
mit Ahnung,
will man auch haben,
er hat gemeint,
übrigens,
faule Leute,
die,
äh,
Übersicht haben,
sind auch super Führungskräfte,
weil,
die können gut delegieren,
faule Leute,
mit Ahnung,
will man auch haben,
weil,
faule Leute,
mit Ahnung,
oftmals,
ziemlich gute Lösungen,
äh,
erarbeiten,
so,
dass sie später,
nicht mehr,
ähm,
da gibt's noch die Kombination,
faul,
und hat keine Ahnung,
da kann man,
eventuell,
auch,
den ein oder anderen,
noch,
ertragen,
von,
aber,
was ganz schlimm ist,
und,
was du auf gar keinen Fall,
haben willst,
ist,
einer,
der super motiviert ist,
und keine Ahnung hat,
warum,
weil er dir alles kaputt macht,
der hat keinen Plan,
was er macht,
ist überall mit dabei,
macht alle Leute verrückt,
und macht alles,
nur noch schlimmer,
also,
das sind die Schlimmsten,
die willst du,
auf gar keinen Fall,
haben,
und,
das,
das hab ich,
in irgendeiner,
in irgendeinem YouTube,
Konferenztalk,
gesehen,
und,
ich finde,
das,
da ist echt,
einiges Wahres dran,
an dieser Tabelle,
die er da gezeigt hat,
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich sie richtig,
zusammenbekommen hab,
zum großen und ganzen hin,
und,
das fand ich echt treffend,
ja,
hiervon gibt's wenige,
die Ahnung haben,
und super motiviert sind,
da hast du natürlich,
das ist natürlich Gold,
Goldgrube für dich,
wenn du so jemand hast,
ja,
Ahnung und faul,
ist auch gut,
ja,
wenn er was macht,
kannst du dich eigentlich drauf verlassen,
dass er sich durchdacht,
das hier,
würde ich mal fast sagen,
das hier ist,
entgegen dem,
was in jeder Stellenanzeige steht,
ja,
ich würd mal behaupten,
das hier ist ein Großteil,
der gescheiten IT-Leute,
ja,
das hier ist ein Großteil,
ich kenn sehr viele IT-Leute,
die wirklich super schlau sind,
aber faul as fuck,
ob ich super schlau bin,
kann ich persönlich nicht beurteilen,
eher nicht,
aber ich bin faul,
und ich überleg mir auch immer zweimal,
wenn ich was gebaut hab,
okay,
funktioniert der Scheiß gut genug,
dass es mir nie wieder auf den Sack geht,
und nur dann,
benutze ich's,
beziehungsweise,
oder nur dann,
dann ist es fertig,
jetzt,
ja,
und das andere passt ja auch,
ne,
und selbst,
wenn du jemand hast,
der keine Ahnung hat,
und faul ist,
das kann ja durchaus auch was Gutes sein,
ja,
vielleicht brauchst du jemanden im Team,
der einfach nur gut für den Zusammenhalt ist,
ja,
faule Leute sind auch super im Sachenautomatisieren,
das ist richtig,
genau,
vielleicht brauchst du einfach,
der nur richtig gut so für den Teamspirit ist,
das kann durchaus auch so jemand sein,
was du halt gar nicht haben willst,
ist das,
ja,
es ist,
das hab ich,
das hab ich schon mal gezeigt vor einer Weile,
ja,
hab ich's in,
in Notepad gemacht,
motiviert keine Ahnung und Produktionsdatenbank-Access,
genau das ist das Problem bei sowas,
ja,
du hast am Endeffekt,
mit so Leuten hast du nur Stress,
und nur Probleme,
also ich weiß nicht,
was das für ein Dozent ist,
aber Anwendungsentwickler und Excel,
passt nicht so wirklich zusammen,
weil man kann Excel-Anwendungen entwickeln,
aber,
es ist nicht so,
dass die meisten Anwendungen in Excel entwickelt würden,
also das,
ist Blödsinn,
ja,
tut so,
als hätte er Ahnung,
ist hier auch,
sehr oft,
zu finden,
und wenn du selbst,
vor einem Thema,
überhaupt keine Ahnung hat,
ist,
keine Ahnung hast,
ist auch schwierig,
ja,
deswegen hab ich,
hab ich meinem Chef empfohlen,
ob er,
wenn er,
für,
ob er nicht,
Set-Server benutzen will,
als Test,
wenn er neue Linux-Leute einbaut,
ja,
einfach,
einfach die Easy-Tests,
mal 1,
2 machen lassen,
und da weißt du schon Bescheid,
ob der grundlegend Ahnung von Linux hat,
weil die Easy-Sachen bei Set-Server,
die sind wirklich so easy,
dass du die auch unter Anspannung,
in ein Vorstellungsgespräch hinkriegst,
und was ich natürlich auch hoffe,
dass,
der vielleicht,
dass wir vielleicht,
ein Premium-Abo kaufen,
für Set-Servers,
weil der,
der Typ hat das auf jeden Fall verdient,
und,
Du musst das Problem lösen und du kriegst am Ende auch angezeigt, ob das passt oder nicht.
Und die Easy-Challenges, die sind wirklich easy.
Das sollte jeder, gerade die ersten fünf oder so,
das sollte jeder, der Linux-Erfahrung hat und sich um Linux-Shop bewirbt,
auch unter Anspannung von einem Vorstellungsgespräch hinkriegen.
Gerade das erste, das ist wirklich super easy.
Ah, Leute, kurz auf mein Handy gucken, nicht, dass es irgendeinen Rufbereitschaftseinsatz oder so gab.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen. Ich bin müde.
Bettge, korrekt.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen. Es wird Zeit.
Ich habe schon lange keinen Gute-Nacht-Song mehr gespielt im Internet.
Im Stream. Aber YouTube entfernt den ja auch immer.
Wie zufrieden seid ihr eigentlich mit Signal 4?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde es jetzt weder gut noch schlecht.
Es spricht wahrscheinlich für das Tool, dass ich gar nicht so oft dran denke,
was ja für so ein Signal- bzw. Alarmierungsservice eigentlich ein ganz gutes...
Nee, ich meinte das gar nicht. Ich habe wirklich nachgedacht.
Nee, nee. Das ist nicht als schlecht zu werten.
Es geht einfach, ja.
Ich hatte damit jetzt noch keine Probleme.
Ich bin seit zehn Wochen am Stück schon on duty in Signal 4.
Ich habe mich da einmal eingeloggt und seitdem geht es halt einfach.
Und wenn was ist, klingelt das Handy. Fertig. Es macht das, was es soll.
Das Webinterface finde ich ein bisschen sehr mittelalterlich.
Was man ja auch schon sieht, wenn man auf die Webseite geht.
Das erste, was runtergeladen wird, ist jQuery.
Das hat relativ viel Unterstützung.
Ja, das erste ist, wenn du auf die Webseite kommst, jQuery.
Also das Webinterface sieht sehr...
Ja, als...
Als wurde es vielleicht von Leuten erstellt, die nicht hauptsächlich Webentwickler sind.
Aber der Rest ist solide und funktioniert.
Es wäre vielleicht jetzt nicht meine persönliche erste Wahl für so einen Notification-Service gewesen,
wenn ich mich da schlau gemacht hätte.
Aber es ist okay.
Es tut, was es soll.
Ich verwende keine Spezialfeatures davon.
Ja, also wir machen da keine Schichtplanung drüber oder sowas.
Es ist einfach nur, solange man sich eingeloggt hat, klingelt das Handy bei einem Alert.
Wenn man sich ausgeloggt hat, nicht.
Datadog ist ganz nice. Ja, weißt du, wofür Datadog auch noch ganz nice ist?
Ups, falsches E-Mode.
Datadog ist auch super nice zum Geldverbrennen.
SAP UI 5...
Moment, Moment, heißt das jetzt nicht...
Fiori oder sowas?
Haben wir nicht letztens gelernt, SAP UI heißt jetzt...
Fiori?
Wie hieß das?
Ich hab's schon wieder... Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, oder?
Doch, Fiori, ja, ja, ja.
Siehste mal.
Kann ich in meine Skill-Liste gleich mal SAP aufnehmen?
Ich hab ein... Ich kann...
Ich kann ein Wort erwähnen und alle denken, ich habe Ahnung von.
Manchmal muss das auch sein.
Herr Endpunkt konnte das richtig gut.
Wenn ich mal irgendwann zufälligerweise Eindruck machen möchte bei SAP-Entwicklern,
da sage ich, ja, SAP-UI, ihr Kack-Noobs, wir machen schon Fiori-Apps.
Dann sagen die alle, boah, Alter, sind die advanced.
Die kennen sich ja voll aus.
Poggers, sagen die dann.
Ich sage, ihr seid richtig Poggers.
Ich habe es einmal bisher nur geschafft, dass jemand auf der Arbeit Poggers gesagt hat.
Die Story habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Nicht in meinem aktuellen Job, aber im letzten habe ich es mal geschafft,
dass einer auf einer offiziellen Präsentation vor, keine Ahnung, 120 Leuten gesagt hat, Poggers.
Ich glaube, da war auch Twitch-Zuschauer.
Nicht bei mir, so allgemein Twitch, weil ansonsten würde niemand Poggers einfach aussprechen auf so einer Präsentation.
Ja, klar, mit dem habe ich letztens sogar mal telefoniert.
Ich habe es aber schon wieder vergessen, was er jetzt macht.
Er macht irgendwas anderes, ist nicht mehr dort, was er in meinem Video erzählt hat und macht jetzt auch Big Stonks.
Eigentlich müsste ich mit Herr Endpunkt mal wieder was aufnehmen, so nach dem Motto,
mein Ex-Azubi, zehn Jahre später oder so, der ist ja auch schon jetzt eine ganze Weile fertig.
Zehn Jahre ist er noch nicht fertig, aber bald.
Der dürfte bald bestimmt auch zehn Jahre oder so fertig sein.
Das wirst du echt mal, mein Ex-Azubi packt aus, zehn Jahre später.
Wenn es nach mir geht, also ich habe da schon immer ein paar blöde Sachen drin, was ich geil fand.
Letzter Laden, wo ich war, hatte ich...
Emojis drinnen, irgendwelche anderen blöden Meme-Bildchen ab und zu, aber nur, wenn es gepasst hat, jetzt nicht total übertrieben oder so.
Und am Ende von der Präsentation, das Einzige, was ihnen aufgefallen ist, also ich lasse die ja immer ein bisschen Probe gucken davor, ja.
Was den Probe-Guckern aufgefallen ist.
Das ist...
Also, niemand hat was gesagt über irgendwelche Meme-Bildchen oder über irgendwelche blöden Emojis oder so in der Präsentation, niemand, ja.
Das, was die gesagt haben, ist nur, oh, da fehlt aber das Logo von der Firma drin.
Das ist kein Corporate Design, die PowerPoint-Vorlage gewesen.
Sagt, ja, ich habe keine Corporate Design-Vorlage genommen.
Ja, das geht ja nicht, das muss Corporate Design-Vorlage sein.
Wenn man sonst keine Probleme hat, ist ja...
Du kannst ein Emoji über die ganze Seite stretchen, das ist egal, aber...
Wenn im Hintergrund nicht die Corporate Design-Powerpoint-Vorlage zu sehen ist, dann ist es vorbei.
Ja, im jetzigen Laden durfte ich noch keine Präsi halten.
Beziehungsweise, ich durfte schon, ich habe es aber noch nicht fertig gekriegt.
Ich darf sogar mehrere machen, wenn ich es mal fertig kriege.
Ich darf was halten zu Linux-Containern.
So, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Zu drei Sachen, zu drei Sachen habe ich...
Das okay quasi, das zu machen.
Linux-Container?
Ah, habe ich es noch am CD, ja.
Terraform und Git, glaube ich, war das?
Ich habe es schon wieder verdrängt.
Ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben.
Ich wollte mit der Linux-Container-Geschichte...
Achso, und bestimmt auch ein bisschen Cloud- und Kubernetes-Zeug.
Ich wollte mit der Linux-Container...
Ich wollte mit der Linux-Container-Vorstellung da mal eigentlich anfangen.
Gerade halt auch für Leute, die damit noch nicht so viel zu tun haben.
Aber ich kriege es einfach zeitlich nicht hin.
Und ich sehe es nicht ein, das privat zu erstellen, wenn es für die Firma ist.
So, aber jetzt...
Ich wollte schon vor zehn Minuten auf.
Schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Chat, wir sehen uns die Tage wieder.
Dann machen wir auch was im Stream.
Heute war Schwätz-Only.
Bad Git-Time jetzt.
Alles klar.
Wir hören uns bis dann.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.